joining us now education secretary
miguel cardona mr secretary welcome to
fox news sunday
thank you trace happy new year happy new
year to you as well sir in an effort to
continue the school year with in-person
learning the cdc recently announced that
students exposed to the virus can safely
continue in-person learning so long as
they are regularly tested for the virus
but now according to burbio that's a for
a firm that tracks these school closures
the closures are really ticking back up
already more than 2100 schools plan to
be closed in the coming week mr
secretary where are we heading exactly
you know we've been very clear our
expectation is for schools to be open
full-time for students
for in-person learning we remember the
impact of school closures on students
last year and our science is better we
have better tools we have 10 billion
dollars in the american rescue plan for
surveillance testing vaccinations are
available now for children ages five and
up we recognize that there may be some
bumps in the road especially this
upcoming week when superintendents who
are working really hard across the
country are getting calls saying that
some of their schools may have five to
ten percent of their staff not available
so any decisions on very short-term or
emergency closures are most likely based
off of staffing issues and ultimately
those are safety issues when you don't
have adequate staff but the goal is
full-time in-person learning for our
students they've suffered enough yeah
you mentioned bumps in the road you know
those schools that plan to remain open
sir including larger school districts
like in new york city los angeles and
d.c have announced strategies centered
very much on testing to stay ahead of
the spread and keep in person learning
but mr secretary how practical in your
estimation is the testing centered
approach when there is a nationwide
testing shortage federal distribution
really still up in the air and new
research now showing that it's
questioning the reliability of detecting
omicron by the widely used rapid test so
how do you square that sir
right you know we know testing is a part
of a overall strategy that should be
used to keep our schools open
vaccination efforts are also a big part
of that strategy and we've seen them
work
i would say that as schools come in they
should be thinking about a testing
strategy to make sure that if students
are having symptoms they can be tested
in school
keeping them in school is critical for
them for our communities for our
families for our parents so it's really
important that the testing protocols are
put in place but they're not done in
isolation increasing vaccination helps
adherence to the mitigation strategies
that we know work uh are also part of
the strategy
yeah what about the school's ability to
carry out these prescriptions this
strategy you talk about you know we've
already seen what an enormous strain the
pandemic has put on the system in terms
of staffing shortages the president of
the american federation of teachers
randy weingarten said the following and
i'm quoting here sir i am concerned that
lots of districts don't have the
infrastructure for testing and test to
stay it's going to be really really
bumpy and there's going to
need a lot of grace and i think the
question is that frustrations are high
and grace among a lot of parents across
the country is in short supply sir
you know there's a level of urgency that
we shouldn't uh lose around making sure
that our children learn in person
the impact of hybrid learning the impact
of remote learning is very real for for
us parents who have had to experience it
at home as well
so we need to do everything in our power
which includes getting access to those
uh
tests let me remind you the american
rescue plan when it came out in march
had funding for testing and thanks to
groups like the rockefeller foundation
contracts were set up early for schools
to have
surveillance testing regularly done in
their schools we see more and more of
that happening and our efforts at the
department of education are to support
districts and states to get contracts
set up so that these systems are robust
so that our students can stay in the
classrooms are you saying the road is
not going to be as bumpy as randy
weingarten says it is
i'll tell you i've been doing this since
march 2020 and uh it's really important
that we continue to work together i do
think there will be bumps in the road
especially tomorrow i mean
superintendents today are receiving
calls of staff members that they were
expecting to be in the classroom
tomorrow who have come down with covid
so we're going to roll up our sleeves
all hands on deck let's keep our
children in the classroom that should be
our default thinking and as problems
come up we need to work together to
solve them mr secretary i want to run
some numbers by you here december saw an
increase of 50 percent in new pediatric
covet cases that's according to the
american academy of pediatrics and went
on to say only 23 percent of 5 to 11
year olds have received one dose of
vaccine are you confident
that the schools even after their best
efforts to remain open for in-person
learning have a plan b just in case of
things like you said staffing shortages
or parents deciding to keep more and
more of their students home
we learned that educators were able to
turn on a dime
when the pandemic first came and we went
to remote learning across the country
and it wasn't ideal but we know that
we're able to adapt the goal however
remains to stay focused on in-person
learning not only for our students
academic needs but for their social
emotional needs
many parents don't have the luxury of
staying home so we have to do everything
possible to keep them in school as our
plan a plan b and plan c obviously if
short-term
emergency closures are necessary schools
should have the tools because they have
the resources to provide an education
that way but that should be the
exception not the rule yeah you talk
about plan b one school district has
already had to modify plans to require
vaccination of students 12 and over
we're talking about the los angeles
unified school district pulled back its
mandate at the last minute when the
california governor newsom and community
activists questioned a a perhaps
unintended consequence meaning that more
than 30 thousand unvaccinated students
would be moved back into distance
learning the district defended the
turnabout as necessary because they did
not have a plan b to stand up remote
learning infrastructure at the last
minute what do you think about that sir
you know i've always said
vaccination decisions need to be made at
the local level and at the state level
but we know
over the last year and a half in those
places where vaccination numbers are
high there's less disruption
there are less students in the hospital
so we need to continue pushing efforts
to provide access to vaccines for our
children vaccination clinics across the
country are happening
we need to protect our students
at the end of the day we want all of our
students back in the classroom but we
want to do it safely yeah we talked
about the grace among parents the
brookings institution which has surveyed
parents four times during the pandemic
found that parental concerns about their
children's well-being had begun to ease
during the summer continued to ease in
october when 93 percent of students were
in person school brookings wrote the
following quoting here this evidence
suggests that the relative normalcy of
in-person learning this year may be
driving reduced parental concerns and of
course sir as you know closures in
school curriculum became hot button
topics in the november election for
virginia governor former education
secretary bill bennett said this
in an interview with fox this week watch
the american people are saying we're not
taking this anymore we don't believe you
yeah mr secretary how do you respond to
that
you know in my travels across the
country over the last eight nine months
i've talked to parents and they want
their children in school they want their
children safe and they want to be heard
parents have put up with a lot over the
last year and a half trying to
balance work and educating their
children so this partnership with
parents needs to continue i want to see
it elevated
as we move forward past the pandemic
and it's really important that we work
together to make sure children are in
the classroom and that they're safe
yeah and parents have been juggling
secretary cardona thank you for coming
on sir happy new year
happy new year take care thank you